okay to people joining this live stream
we are looking at uh
some wolfram language design this is our
incremental language design meeting
series
and we have a variety of topics um first
we're talking about threaded which is a
very lovely thing coming in the next
version
um
and
uh
this is documentation
boy those look a little bit a little bit
old school mainframe
why are they boxes like that
is that because they can be any number
who can speak to what this is
is robert here
those are the levels right the the
levels in the well no the box in the
first one and that's why we use
different colors and in the first one
the boxes are you know places for
for elements or you know possibly
subarrays
um why are they three-dimensional
because they can represent something
with their additional dimensions lower
down they could potentially they don't
have to be three-dimensional we just
thought that that looked a lot nicer
than just
i mean i originally had something
written out in two-dimensional and it
wasn't
i mean the virtual elements which are
the
the grade ones were not as obvious
i see
um
okay but but of course it could be
higher dimensional but this is for the
blue the blue gray one is really
two two-dimensional
the the gray
the gray green ones are are
multi-dimensional but right each one of
those
boxes in green or gray is a level right
it's right so dimensionality right so
the blue represents elements and the
green we chose a different color after
that the problem is that you've got the
same iconography of boxes and that's not
right
in this case here these represent levels
right right
so you shouldn't have boxes here because
these are these are just abstract levels
they're not
i mean you need different iconography do
we have somebody from design here
we do not i mean we bet that we did this
with him
okay
okay well is tim here
no i can ask for tim you know you could
get tim and he he yeah that would be
useful actually okay
all right this isn't right you can't
have the same iconography for this case
in this case
you got you see why i'm saying that sure
i mean we chose we chose different
colors but you know but you're probably
right the akan offices should be should
be a bit different i mean maybe they
could be
you know ellipses for the dimensions or
something like that um yeah i don't know
but it should be different
um okay but let's look at functionality
here
um
yeah okay i mean maybe you could have
one more basic example um
uh
i do think that that showing this is a
basic example that you can have
arithmetic on the threaded
i mean
what's the case in terms of the threaded
i see
so you have scalar arithmetic on
threaded
yes
yes
this is a very nice construct by the way
yeah i think people are going to find it
super useful
yeah
and the implementation is efficient
right
well not not not not as efficient as it
can be yet you know it's still
uh your mark is mark is still working
through
a whole bunch of parallelization stuff
so that we really get it right so that
probably won't be
in this version but it will be
and and once that's done it'll be super
efficient
right but we're talking about sort of a
factor of two right not effective well
it depends it depends on the sizes you
use it can be it can be it can be as
little as one and a half a factor of one
and a half but it can be as big as a
factor of
you know five or more depending on
you know the it depends on how things
get unpacked
okay
ethan on our live stream is pointing out
that thread should work with image
channel data isn't that exactly what
it's doing here
yeah that's that's that's the point of
that example
okay
and it's also pointing out i had a
target device
for like
doing things on gpus is that plausible
that's i think has to await compiler
stuff doesn't it that that has to wait
uh yes that i mean ultimately yes and
the point is you'll be able to use
threaded with i mean i've written the
code so threaded works within the
compiler as well
um you know not at full efficiency yet
until mark gets his magic done but but
yes so so you can use thread within
compiler and then when we compile the
gpus that should just work
this is great it's a great piece of
functionality let me just look at the
documentation here
will b automatically be threaded fix
oh right okay sorry i missed it will
automatically be threaded into the
lowest level of an array when used in a
listable operation such as plus
are you sure there isn't a way to write
this out with a b1 b2b3
but that's actually what we originally
had and you said you didn't like it okay
fine
yeah okay um
fine
okay did we get tim or not
we can
or just just look
what we need what is the right way to
show a level
and i think there may be iconography
that we have in the trees project for
showing levels
we might investigate that
do you get what i'm saying okay well
yeah so so jose and i will work with tim
to try and get the i can offer you right
then we'll
then we'll merge the branch and make
this live okay let's go emerge the
branch you can go ahead and merge the
branch okay let's go ahead and merge the
branch this is close enough i mean it's
just
graphics
so the thing here is that we have to
represent two different things the fact
that we are threading through a bunch of
levels and the one which we are using to
align those two sets i agree i
understand oh align two sets what do you
mean a line
so you see that there are some green
levels and one of them is kind of a
darker green
the darker green is the alignment level
the other ones follow
because we always have to thread through
all levels of b
right
i need to be working with some designer
if i'm going to have opinions about this
this is we need an idea here but but
definitely lose the three-dimensionality
on
on this thing here i i would say
how to represent a level
i mean in a sense this is like a tree
you know this is going down a tree is it
not
if we were to draw the tensor as a tree
these will be
right it doesn't have a single root
right i mean these
right each one of these things
represents a slot if if you're going to
use a tensor
right tensor thought an index right each
one of these is an index
but these are indices like t
a blank b
blank and
yeah they're different so these are
this is right right so if you have a
tensor t abc right then the top
rectangle is a the middle rectangle is b
and the lowest rectangle is c is that
right or is it a tensor a b c d where it
could be that one of them is b and one
of them is d
no it's i don't think it's all the
indices of the tensor that you're
representing here is it
or am i confused
well i guess the the first and last ones
are
right so this is your picking out a
tensor index in the middle of the list
of indices
you're using one of them as the anchor
index
and then the other one here
is
the index b lab that has gone down i
don't quite understand this why isn't
that oa level wait a minute
that's
yeah so let's think of threaded sorry of
of of map thread in map thread
one threads through n levels which is
the third argument
so that's what we are doing always here
we are always threading through as many
levels as b has
yes i get it
and those are the green levels
so that's why on on the right
it's they're all threaded on the left
only the green levels are threaded
yeah i understand i understand
um
i think you should label this whole
stack as being a this whole stack as
being b
that's one thing that would be helpful i
think
um
right you're right i guess that right i
guess the point is right that the dark
green one is the first index of
of b
the lighter green one is the last index
of b
and then
you know the
when you switch over to the a right
those are the corresponding indices in a
wherever they may be okay so i've got a
suggestion
first of all this these are contiguous
levels this dot dot is not contiguous
here they are contiguous i would draw
them out as just unlabeled green boxes
see what i'm saying
lose the lose the light green dark green
and just there's a labeled green box and
then a bunch of green boxes and then
another you know because if you've got
like thin green boxes here nobody's
going to count the green boxes and think
it always has to be that number of green
boxes but the point is that that dot dot
dot means something different from that
dot dot dot there
because all the contiguous b levels are
used
right yes yes i mean they're still
contiguous it's just they're yeah
all the dot dot dots are contiguous
that one is not contiguous yes it is yes
yes it is you're starting from one until
you get to n minus one no no no no no no
i know but you're you're dropping those
things there you're not using them right
whereas here every single level from
from one to i
is used here
right so i think what you're saying is
that it's not clear in this diagram
whether the
dot are gray or green
yes that's right maybe if you had arrows
pointing from the
a dim alev to b dim one and
likewise for that lighter green to the b
dim i
you make that correspondence clear
yeah that's fine i mean i look what
you've got to do is these ones like
connect here that's what i mean arrows
right between those but i wouldn't put
dot dots i would just have because this
is a contiguous thing it's like you're
taking this whole tensor this whole
range of tensor indices
okay just
i i'm not going to do this without
graphic design okay so i think my
suggestion is you have a bunch of green
boxes here unlabeled in the middle you
label the end ones you have dot dots
there
and
you know that's how you do it okay and i
and i agree with you that having
something that indicates that these are
the combined things like have the plus
sign
sit in here
you get what i'm saying
yeah that would be good yep
yeah
okay okay we can take that
okay fine yeah
um
i'm not wild about the
three-dimensionality here unless it
means something
okay if it really means something if it
means that these are being listably
added
then fine if it doesn't mean that and i
would not have three dimensionality
i'm making sense
does it mean that or does it not mean
that
it could mean that
this could be generalized to three
dimensions but
it we would have to be very careful
about how things work yeah so it's very
difficult to infer from this diagram
what's going to happen
stop the three-dimensionality right so
then
some different iconography for
dimensions to make it clear no no no
it'll be okay if you drop the
three-dimensionality here you drop the
yes you're gonna need different
iconography but it's gonna be much more
straightforward to get it
not going to do this without design
so we don't okay
let's not do this right now
okay splice
so we added a second argument to spice
that specifies the head um
basically wonderful
okay do we see an example here yes the
head head splicing
yes and it it uses patterns in the
second argument as you suggested
okay
maybe we should show an example of that
even in basic examples because that
seems pretty useful to me like putting a
blank there will just splice into any
head
right there are examples in scope i
think but but not in basic
i would put a blank there and just say
the splices into anything
the last one of of scope is one first no
it's not a pure blank it's not a it's
not a oh i'm saying a pure blank
steel blank it will splice into anything
it's like just like sequence with a pure
blankets just like sequence isn't it
well yes
but blank right blank of f is
is basically a pure blank it's not it's
it's an f it's a headdressed thing
oh
okay i didn't
right and that's perfectly a good
example i like that example it's just
there's a more basic example which is
just a pure blank
yep i think there is a note saying
explicitly that okay
and you should also show it in in
properties and relations oh look at that
you do well except you you should show
it with an actual blank that's the next
one
brilliant
okay
good
okay looking good all right delete
adjacent duplicates
so this was a function we talked about a
while ago um danny has implemented it
we're uh finishing up the documentation
here but i had a couple of questions
about
um
[Music]
if we wanted some related functionality
and just to make sure what about the
same test
does it have the same test it does have
a test yep yes second argument
and we want a second argument as opposed
to same test option
we have both things in different
functions for example
delete duplicates
has a test or tally like this
okay yes
okay
what was the question
well so delete duplicates also has a buy
version and i wasn't sure if we wanted
to generalize this to have a buy version
i mean
it seems a little bit on the niche side
it does it really does i would wait
until the users clamor for it yes like
going that step
right
right okay and then there's also a
predicate version of delete duplicates
or i guess duplicate free um i'm
guessing adjacent duplicate free is
going to be a little niche
also i'm trying to round out don't don't
i wouldn't put that in i mean maybe it's
a wfr for that yeah i was going to say
that could be good
all right that's easy enough then
i started looking at positions
largest smallest and the buy versions um
danny's also taking some look here yeah
i'm actually i started working on it
today for real
okay
you know i think i can just do it
yeah so i have a question about whether
we want to have a second argument
um in terms of n largest values because
we start to run into a question of how
we handle multiplicity you know if i say
i want the n
i want the three largest values do i
want
effectively what takes largest threes
i understand the question is this is
that list
of length equal to that number or are
you asking
i understand or are you asking for the
things if you were to rank order all the
things the things
of those ranks so to speak return
i i would say the latter because that's
the non-trivial interpretation
the other can be done with take largest
well i would say that
the question is whether we want to
generalize technologies to do that too
which would be very useful
to do what
of the many things that now
technologists can report i think
reporting multiplicity would be great
wait a second take largest
does report multiplicity as in it just
returns things of that right
no no
i mean the error notation the annotation
in which we can use now
value
index
i think you'd be trying to um
[Music]
tack on to take largest something that's
really a bit out of its realm jose
okay so hold on property can be
the element the index
yes the multiplicity no but but the
point is that take largest is simply
returning a subset of lists
okay so if there is a multiplicity of
things
that are all largest
those things will be returned with their
multiplicity
as opposed to processing whether it's
index or not i mean if we say take
largest um
and then we say something like one one
you know
three four
five five
okay and we say take largest comma three
we'll get that
right
and that's why i'm arguing that the rank
interpretation for position largest
actually gives something new
okay hold on hold on hold on hold on
hold on so let me understand this so
this is okay that's the index those are
the indices
but i don't think
uh
right right i don't see what
multiplicity would do
so my point here is that
it's very it's typically very difficult
to know how many there are of the
largest
unless you call tally and rank and tally
everything so i think what we are
missing is a function that can tally
just the largest the few largest
i understand i understand because
because if this were
that number three it's just a guess
and the question is i don't know how
long that the the largest are correct
why isn't okay so what we have right now
is we have communist for example which
gives us
what what you're asking for
no what commonest will just okay
what you one thing you could ask for is
give me a list of
okay here's here's a function that would
be useful potentially maybe
am i confused here
i think perhaps what i'm asking for is
tally with give me just the three
largest no you know what you need what
you need is a second argument look what
you need is this
take largest
hold on hold on hold on it's a little
bit like the nearest um where you have a
radius and an and a count yes that's
right but what about something like this
take largest automatic
which would then give us the um
uh
instead of giving take largest a
particular number
um
uh
um
um i actually think that the nearest
interface is the closest we're going to
get to something that would
we could retrofit
but what what what do you think of this
idea
i don't know what automatic would mean
oh what what it means is oh take give
give me all the ones that are tied for
the last
yes
about up to
so up to one means yeah but but then do
i just
but you you have then you have an
ambiguity in what the n argument means
if you're going to keep that n argument
well n is a
like uh ordinal
oh
over here
so up to two would mean give me all of
the things that are in the top two ranks
too unique
like too unique without their
multiplicities
yeah that's what i mean by ranks yeah
yeah the the top largest unique values
okay but there's a problem with that
which is what if i say take largest look
if i do this and maybe i'm maybe i'm
wrong and how this works but if i say
take largest here
i think we already have an up to meaning
well i know we do because because here's
what it is if i say up to eight yeah
right
yep
yep yep so we we we're gonna we've
already used that so let's take a look
at the nearest thing
so it would be
um
radius comma count i believe
and so you might have a radius of of
zero but that only works to get your
very largest
so it would be zero comma infinity
give me as many as possible
that are exactly equally obscured yeah i
understand it's obscure
well not only that but it doesn't
generalize if you want more than one
rank more than the top rank
right
so what we want
really what it is is instead of the
count
we want the ranks
instead of that second argument being a
count of the number of elements
we wanted to give say give the our
largest ranks
give everybody in the our largest ranks
right
so although either it's a
you know one case is count of elements
and the other one
count of ranks
as a general comment up to
there should be a second
alternative to up to that takes into
cardinals and not originals because it's
always confusing
what it does what it means usually i
think of the up to as
up to infinity means all
but if you use it in a span
in a part for example it doesn't
has this meaning
what does it mean
well it doesn't work usually if it's
like a first argument
it's confusing so if you say take
if you use part part with the span
oh i see okay
this in some way reminds me of the
differentiation and bin specs in
histogram where we have
and we use a list notation to
differentiate there
no it's not my favorite either but i
mean the possibility would be a rank
here
that that could mean
the top rank
yeah my other thought was some sort of
headdress but i i it's maybe going to be
specific to say rank
one
like with an explicit head
well i wonder whether there's other
places where that's useful
yeah i mean the only existing functions
we have that have rank is a
a prefix are ranked max and rankman
which are related to this yeah they are
related to it um what do they do do they
do exactly this
no they do
no so i think take largest is and danny
can correct me if i'm wrong but i think
it's based on some of the internals of
rank max where that's giving me
that's correct largest element so
yeah there's code shared
okay the nth largest element
as opposed to
the
elements which are the nth largest
elements
right
right this is the nth element of
technologist
again cardinal versus ordinal
it would be nice to have a distinguished
just
to distinguish those
let me understand that statement um
let me understand that so so the the
function that
is the missing function here
is
give me the things
okay so what we are missing is give me
all
the nth ranked
give me all the elements
in the nth size rank
right that's that's the function we
don't have
that
correct
right that is what we will be doing is
we'll be taking this
and to rank them
how do we how do we put these
how do we tally these by rank we would
say
what will we do we say sort
how do we tally these by rank i mean we
could say
counts and then we could say sort of
counts
so for this tally and then reverse sword
by last it's very useful
okay which is equivalent to this
it's just coincidentally ordered in
tally there but
indeed right
right it's not even ordered i mean oh
yeah
i i
every time i use tally i always use
reverse
sort by
yeah i think i think we did we did well
in in tech largest to sort things
here it's missing
yes well i mean i also do that for
counts i often sort counts
or sometimes like key sword counts but
actually the fact that you can do both
of them is very useful both key sort and
sort
if you understand what i'm saying yep
um okay let me understand next comment
about cardinals versus ordinals can we
unpack that for a second
so what's an example okay let me let me
just understand
um
what is a quintessential example for us
an ordinal case is something like part
specification is that what you is that
what you mean
yeah usually uh
what do you know is a
when you specify a span for part
specification those as an integer it's
an ordinal
i see what you're saying so so you're
saying an ordinal
is like
a okay so so the the the difference
would be
give me
certain elements of a list as opposed to
give me the five largest elements of the
list give me give me
you know in other words okay so the
claim would be
take of a list
is ordinarily
getting me like two elements of the list
right
whereas are you claiming
that take largest
is somehow
cardinally giving me
is that right
well communist is certainly
i confused here
can you explain i'm i'm anybody
understand i'm slightly confused so my
view of this is that indices or position
specs are ordinals and lengths are
cardinals
i see so for example when we discuss
your remember when we discuss infinite
lists
and we were trying to join two infinite
lists so the question is
what's the position
of the first element of the second
infinite list
yes
and so okay so you're saying okay so
you're basically claiming
that
length
of infinite list
you claim
is
you know aleph zero or whatever
that's
whereas you're claiming that
the index
let's see what will be the um
uh
how do we even get that the position of
the last element
last range
for example i think it's clear if we
have two infinite lists the first one is
a one a two a three a four
a infinity and the second one is b one b
two b b three if we join them what's the
position of b one
the answer should be yeah right omega
plus one
yes
okay so you're saying
i don't know how i exactly do this but
but um
let's say
well i mean here by the way when we have
an infinite list presumably we will have
a generator here a generation function
so let's say our generator function is
like that
um and you're saying join of this
to
infinite list
b ampersand
and then we say
first position
of b
no i would say position of b one
well i i i just b ampersand so i oh i
see i see yeah yeah so that will be
omega
plus one
right
right
right do we actually understand the i
mean we've had a couple of
implementations of infinite lists do we
actually understand how this will work
in terms of transphonic numbers and so
on
is that
is that something within range or is
that not within range i i kind of think
i mean i kind of think this is something
we should be i mean as we think about
these evaluation graphs and so on we're
going to have to deal with this
but okay let's let's come back to this
so
just this is one thing the fundamental
problem was that
we need a non-commutative plus and so we
cannot use plus because one plus omega
is is omega but omega plus one is this
omega plus one
what about up values on the carbon on
the ordinals
i i don't think we can i mean plus we
will fire immediately and do something
not if there's an up value not if not if
omega
is you know ordinal number
you know blah blah blah what is that
what if there's an up value an ordinal
number
but but do up values overwrite the
orderless attribute f plus
oh
right
i see
i see
that's a bugasaurus
huh that's an interesting problem
uh
well i mean the real issue i think is
that you know cantor normal form or
whatever we're going to use to represent
these numbers
you know that's kind of like digits
this is a solvable problem i don't see
the solution immediately but there's a
explain to me how we think about okay
here's a naive question
the trans-finite numbers
okay this is a super naive question i
should know the answer to this anybody
know the um
the relationship between the piano
axioms and transfinite numbers
do the to the transfinite numbers i mean
they are not integers in the sense of
satisfying the piano axioms presumably
or am i confused about that
i don't know i don't know the answer
okay we need to
we should have a discussion about
numbers and infinite lists i think we
can solve this now and i think we need
to solve it because i think we need this
concept we need to generalize the idea
of transfinite numbers to transfinite uh
graphs and so on
um because that's what we're going to
need for these evaluation graphs
anyway okay that's an irrelevant point
okay let's come back to the points here
okay so what we need is something where
we are
asking for so
so nick is commenting that up to
i mean i agree but i think that's a
symptom not the cause that up to in one
case is a cardinal designator and the
other case is an ordinal designator
intake
largest um but the question is how do we
get
everything of the first rank
versus
everything
i mean
okay
ranked max is the nth largest
now does rank
max it doesn't have a
um
doesn't it allow to take a range
doesn't look like it
looks like it's just the
because after all
i mean that that's the question is
whether you could have
the nth through empth
largest elements
right that may be where the
the place to attack this not not through
take largest but through rank max
since it has rank in the name
well but you're suggesting that a rank
max of list comma and comma multiplicity
could give i mean so that's one
possibility is that we could say that i
don't like it because it's going to be
change the type of output but anyway
ranked max
of list comma and comma multiplicity
and that if multiplicity is all
i mean i don't like it because it's
going to give a list
yeah i i wasn't even thinking in terms
of um
um
giving a multiplicity but i guess we
would need to
because right now it only returns an
individual value
right but what you're saying is
what we want
is
the
okay so first we were talking about
position largest right so
the question is is this a rank
or is this
simply a takes back
and
danny is arguing that it should be a
rank because that's more useful
the concern is how different that is
from take largest
right yeah
um
all right just to throw another monkey
wrench in the thing raj and i working on
a set of commands called partial
ordering and polisher sort
which for a one-dimensional list would
does a sort but it it lists the elements
by their rank
right lists the elements by their rank
say that again what is the one
dimensional for for a one-dimensional
list
what is it called
partial sort right okay and what does it
do again it's well it
it it generalizes to multiple dimensions
where it finds
sort of you know it finds ranks of
elements in you know the plane or
higher dimensions that are not dominated
by other points but the but the
one-dimensional case is very similar to
what you're talking about here
so like partial sort parser sort of say
one two three one would give the list
uh
a list of list one one
comma two comma list comma two
comma 3. so it so it gives a sub list
for each rank
hold on hold on hold on hold on
why isn't that just
split
of sort
because because because there's the
generalization to
two and higher dimensions
okay which relate to those remember
those vector inequalities the vector
less equal the vector greater equal
and so
yeah so this may be a little unrelated
but that the 1d case does sort of
overlap i don't like the name i don't
like the name at all
i don't think i need to be sold on the
name yeah
um
because the whole concept of partial
orderings is something that we need to
do a lot more with post sets partial
orderings and so on i don't think we
want to use up this name for this
concept
well learn that this is just the one
diver yeah the the whole the concept we
have of partial sort and partial
ordering is is related to the whole
pulsat thing
okay but it's a very special case of
both sets isn't it
yeah yeah so so so fine so i just
thought okay okay all right okay so
let's come back to the question of and
we have to wrap in just a minute here
unfortunately for right now um and i
that's i know that's a shame because
danny is in the middle of trying to
implement this
that's
um
right
the
i don't have an immediate thought here i
think this is i mean this is a
well-exposed issue i think we are going
to need
again so one solution which i don't like
very much is the braced
second argument to take largest
it seems like the consensus is it is
useful to be able to
generate the ranked results it is just a
question of what the best way to do that
is so maybe we'll do some brainstorming
and for now we can work on the single
argument version
of position largest
and the buy functions and yeah
think about this as right
remind me
um what does ranked max do
when there's ties
uh
so ranked mac there's an example on the
page right there at the very bottom
ranked max or on the agenda
if there's two instances of the largest
value
then
it will give the largest value for the
second
i'd say okay so it's not giving back
rank the second argument isn't the rank
it is the
and florida
it's an it's a a raw number so to say
yeah okay got it well so just saying so
the numbers are put in their rank order
and then
the bucket
whatever number it is that is in the
second bucket
is what is returned no no that's not no
no no
it's it's
tantamount to order uh comma negative
two
in that example
or the element that is at that position
okay this requires more thought guys
yeah yeah i was wondering if there was a
potential shortcut here but there isn't
okay
okay
to be continued
see you guys soon